Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in Alwajis
and we left off yesterday morning
discussing
the eighth and final
type of neessa of filth that the
author has mentioned here in listing the
various types of nessa, the various
types of filth. And the eighth and final
nessa that he mentioned was ala
and that is a dead animal. A dead animal
meaning
even
those animals which are otherwise
permissible to eat. So a dead chicken, a
dead cow, a dead rooster, a dead duck, a
dead goose, whatever is permissible to
eat, if it has not been slaughtered
properly,
then it is considered to be
dead. Ma. Now this word ma,
it has a linguistic meaning. Something
is dead. But in this context, it has a
very specific meaning. in Islamic
legislation.
And that is
[Silence]
whatever dies without being
slaughtered properly, right?
And there are some exceptions to this
rule. There are namely three exceptions
to this rule.
So the first exception which we
discussed yesterday
was
one type of ma that is on the land
and all ma that is in the sea. So this
only applies to land dwelling animals.
Animals which are aquatic. All aquatic
animals, no matter what they look like,
no matter where they reside in fresh
water or in salt water,
are permissible for a person to eat
and they do not need to be slaughtered
in the Islamic fashion. Even if a
person comes upon them already dead,
even if they were caught, killed
by you know non-Muslim, any kind of
person in any way, it will be
permissible to eat, right? So any type
of fish whether it has tentacles or
whether it has a shell or whether it
looks you know no matter what it
looks it is permissible to eat.
Even if it's a carnivore, even if it is
an herbivore, whatever it is,
anything that resides in the sea is
permissible to eat whether it has been
caught
live or dead. Right? And the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam described
the sea, described the water. He said,
[Silence]
That its water is pure and purifying
and its dead is permissible to eat.
[Silence]
The next exempt from that rule of is
locust and we discussed this yesterday
in detail, right? Locust, a big type of
bug, looks almost a grasshopper.
They come in swarms, right? , al jar
fa
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam says in
a narration collected by Ahmed in his
in his a very well-known narration on
the authority of Omar.
[Silence]
He says,
, two types of dead and two types of
blood are permissible for us to eat. The
two types of dead are
the aquatic
and
jar locus. And the two types of blood
are the liver and the spleen.
The liver and the spleen.
These two organs in the animal, they
contain a lot of blood. Even in human
beings, the liver and the spleen, they
are just essentially blood banks, right?
And if a person were to try to purge the
blood out of these organs
entirely before eating them, it would be
next to impossible.
So the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam has informed us that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has overlooked that
even though there is a high amount of
blood in the liver and the spleen they
are still permissible to eat from any
animal which is permissible to eat.
The next type of exemption from al-mea
from the general rule of the dead a dead
animal is
[Silence]
What?
The second is anything that does not
have blood that flows
through veins a human being or
an animal does. And the scholars what
they mean by this is animals that are
more akin to insects. Right? So bees,
, spiders,
, ants,
you know, flies, mosquitoes, things like
that. These things do not have blood
that flows,
right? And so because of that, the
scholars define it as not having blood
that flows other animals. And so it
is not considered a type of filth. Now
notice
it is not considered a type of filth.
But that doesn't mean that it is
necessarily permissible to eat. This is
one of the eases that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has given us in order to not make
things difficult for us. Otherwise, if a
person's supposed to keep his clothing
and his shoes and his house and so forth
clean of you know dead insects, dead
ants, dead you know they're making
salah etc. This would be very difficult.
It'd be very very difficult
and so these things are not considered
to be u filthy but it's not permissible
to eat bees. The prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam in prohibited that bees be
killed. He prohibited that ants be
killed. Right? As well it is not
permissible to eat insects.
And the evidence that the author cites
here for this is a narration which is
collected by
it's a well-known narration.
And
[Silence]
And so the evidence for this that he
cites is an erration on the authority
in which the messenger of Allah
sallall.aii Wasam
said, "If a fly lands in your cup, in
your glass of water, in something that
you are drinking, then dip it entirely
into the water before taking it out and
throwing it away." Because
on one of its wings there is an illness
and on the other wing there is its
antidote.
Now what is this illness? What is its
antidote? Allah. But it's an authentic
narration. The prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam mentioned that if a fly lands
on
in in a person's glass of water or
what have you, especially if it's hot
hot water boiling, right? And you dip
it into the water, it's going to die.
But it doesn't make it neg right that's
the evidence that he's using here and
that's the evidence that the scholars of
Phil took from this narration and so he
is saying that if the fly lands in the
water when it lands it always lands with
one of its
wings up usually he says to dip it in
before then taking it out and throwing
it away. Why? Because on one of its
wings is an illness and on the other
wing, the opposite wing is its antidote.
What is it? Allah. The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. This is what he
commanded.
And so this is the evidence that the
author uses for this. There is a final
third thing which is exempt from al the
dead and we the dead animal and we will
[Arabic recitation]